en prison vous dites qu'il y a pas il y
a pas de drogue évidemment il y a pas
d'héroïne mais il y a la fiole c'est
quoi la fiole
ça va ça va ça se passe mieux que la
dernière fois que tu es venu là pour
marcher non j'arrive à escalader un
petit peu comment ça prend l'habitude
alors Guillaume Depardieu acteurs de
cinéma tous les matins du monde cibler
mouvants les apprentis César du meilleur
espoir Paula x Marthe pot d'ange aime
ton père donc régulièrement à l'affiche
au cinéma mais aussi souvent Guillaume
Depardieu à la une des médias
prison ferme pour revendre d'héroïne en
1993 accident de moto en 1995 amputation
de la jambe en 2003 puis altercation a
Trouville avec un pistolet à grenaille 9
mois avec sur 6 5000 euros d'amende ça
voilà donc vous êtes un garçon à la fois
qu'on retrouve sur les affiches des
films mais elle a une et elle a une des
médias et c'est pas fini puisque vous
publiez ces plans un livre d'entretien
réalisé avec Marc-Olivier Fogiel
depuis qu'il est le dimanche soir c'est
plus mon ami quand même à quoi ça tient
la Mickey un jour après et puis tout va
bien tu vas te réconcilier avec lui et
sur ce plateau très volontiers voilà
donc un livre qui va faire grand bruit
et qui s'appelle tout donner
[Musique]
c'est la seule façon
alors Guillaume depuis la publication
des bonnes feuilles de ce livre dans
Paris Match tout le monde en parle c'est
le cas de le dire et d'ailleurs la
première mise en place chez les
libraires a été mercredi dernier de 80
000 exemplaires
alors au départ c'est Muriel Belair qui
était éditeur chez plomb qui lit un
portrait de vous dans elle qui vous
appelle et qui vous dit vous avez une
vraie histoire à raconter vous dites
vous tombez bien j'ai envie d'écrire
donc voilà donc Muriel Bel Air pour
accoucher de ce témoignage contact
Marc-Olivier Fogiel avec qui vous êtes
amis depuis 1997 et donc c'est Marco qui
vous a accouché alors au niveau de la
méthode de travail avant de passer au
contenu du livre lui dit tous les jours
entre septembre et décembre 2003 j'étais
chez Guillaume à Bougival tête baise sur
son lit
avec un magnéto en marche pendant trois
heures par jour et vous dans le même
dans le même journal vous dites qu'en
fait vous avez enregistré 8 entretiens
avec lui c'est quoi alors il y a 8
entretiens d'une heure en fait et puis
non non mais ça ça doit être le
journaliste qui a du qui s'est trompé
peut-être la vérité c'est ça si vous
avez fait 8 entretien d'une heure avec
lui peut-être belge sur le lit Thierry
bien alors on va y aller
[Applaudissements]
alors le livre commence à votre
naissance vous dites je ne suis pas des
normes ma mère a pris un médicament le
distillen qui a été ensuite interdit à
cause de ses effets secondaires il y a
eu 300 cas de jeunes filles qui sont nés
stériles et vous vous avez eu des
malformations corporelles dites-vous des
eaux en plus
les trucs comme ça des eaux en plus un
cerveau en moi
et où des eaux en plus dans le bras et
on les a enlevés
et le sexe l'opération du sexe ça c'est
plus marquant quand même c'est toi la
puberté quand ça commence à bien
frétiller
déjà tout petit vous vous sentez
différent voilà c'est ça surtout que ça
ben oui ça m'a empêché d'aller en classe
je crois que tu as un appel
ma confiance tu sais c'est mon métier
mais il a pas sonné quoi il a vibré il a
dit
ok ça y est on continue tu es chiant
avec ça
donc tout petit déjà vous vous sentez
très différent des autres
voilà alors vous parlez aussi de vos
rapports avec votre père vous dites les
rapports avec mon père sont pas normaux
non plus ils travaillaient tout le temps
je le voyais jamais il était pas
compatissant de ce que vous viviez à
l'école c'est-à-dire qu'à l'école on
vous emmerdait à cause des valseuses à
cause d'un certain nombre de films que
votre père avait fait et en fait jamais
il vous a dit c'est pas grave laisse
tomber Guillaume c'est des connards il
n'était pas compatissant non mais c'est
même pas ça d'être compatissant ou pas
c'était je sais pas moi j'avais pas de
je savais pas comment réagir vis-à-vis
de ça donc généralement bon ça donnait
des soucis quoi je me battais tout le
temps quoi
vous dites mon père il m'a eu trop tôt
mais je confirme
genre Depardieu en plus il peut pas trop
vous aider parce qu'il est pas beaucoup
à l'école non plus donc
c'est touchant
et alors vers 13 14 ans vous commencez à
plus rien [__] vous commencez à fumer
du shit à sniffer de la colle donc c'est
quand même assez jeune
vous dites j'étais devenu quasiment
autiste oui parce que je n'aimais pas du
tout le
monde qui m'entourage je trouvais ça un
peu ennuyant ennuyeux et donc bon je me
réfugiais surtout dans la musique
quoi de tout mais beaucoup de punks
et la nuit vous preniez le dernier train
pour pour Paris vous allez à Paris vous
marchiez dans les rues pendant toute la
nuit le matin vous preniez le premier
train pour rentrer à Bougival vous
faisiez quoi la nuit déambuler un peu
dans Paris quoi j'apprenais je
m'inventais des identités j'allais dans
les bars j'étais soit fils de notaire
soit fils de
militaires soit des trucs bizarres enfin
des trucs comme ça mais chaque fois
j'avais le privilège de l'anonymat donc
c'est comme ça en fait que je me suis
d'abord j'ai compris que on pouvait
avec un peu de persuasion et en bobine
et tout le monde donc c'est assez
intéressant et puis ça m'a permis de
découvrir plein de l'univers différents
vous disiez jamais que vous étiez le
fils de Gérard Depardieu jamais
maintenant sinon c'était pas drôle la
saison vous décidez comme ça un jour sur
un coup de tête de devenir mercenaire de
partir en Afrique l'arme au point pour
contrôler les ressources pétrolières et
minières et [__] l'Occident dans la
merde ça c'était une une grande idée que
vous aviez
vous étiez vraiment prêt à partir ouais
bien sûr
bien sûr c'est pour ça que j'ai une
petite barbe trots
c'est beaucoup plus beaucoup plus génial
ça c'était une semaine où il y ait
mercenaire et puis la semaine d'après
vous écoutez le Requiem de Mozart vous
fondez en larmes et vous dites c'est ça
que je veux être c'est Mozart quoi c'est
un peu résumé comme ça ça fait un peu
mais c'est ça c'est ça
non en fait je voulais vraiment me
barrer pour quelque chose qui valait le
coup et puis finalement bon j'ai eu de
la chance de d'écouter Mozart quoi parce
que sinon je me barre et c'est vous a
retenu ici non c'est une certaine
manière c'est la donnée un sens au fait
que je sois ici en Occident je me suis
dit on peut on peut arriver au même
chose le but mais en construisant et pas
en détruisant voilà
alors à l'époque vous avez besoin de
l'argent vous n'êtes pas d'argent votre
père non
[Rires]
vous êtes gigolo
c'est pas pour pas que pour l'argent
c'est pareil pour la curiosité aussi
bien sûr
donc vous êtes gigolo pour pour femme
pour homme vous commencez avec des
femmes mûres vous aimez bien les femmes
mûres donc là c'était pas tellement
pénible non non c'était plutôt
gigolo de luxe quoi vraiment j'avais le
choix
plus agréable
et puis avec des mecs aussi
vous racontez le premier mec le premier
ouais 14 ans
et après c'était plus sérieux
c'est arrivé
[Musique]
vous avez appris quoi dans cette
expérience
j'avais tourné le dos
je me suis non non j'ai appris plein de
choses j'ai appris que c'était dans la
tête aussi les choses c'était très lié
heureusement quand vous vous retrouvez
en tôle la première fois il y a un caïd
qui vous protège et vous échapper à
aussi visuels habituels des prisons ou
enfin aussi vie sexuelle non je pense
pas que
que j'étais une proie à ce niveau là
mais
non j'ai échappé surtout un chat
c'est pas encore pour usage de de
stupéfiant c'est pour braquage de Weston
et de l'époque la ça va encore enfin bon
et puis est-ce qu'on met des doudoune
et puis vers 18 ans vous commencez à
mettre le nez dans la poudre ça va durer
6 ans
j'ai perdu 6 ans de ma vie là-dedans
ouais mais je le pense
si mais ça m'a apporté justement mais
rétrospectivement parce que je m'en suis
sorti mais parce que je suis costaud
quand même non mais j'en connais tous
mes potes de l'époque sont pas sortis
ils sont soit devenus fous soit ils sont
morts soit ils ont fait
le mec qui vous a branché dans dans la
drogue dans la poudre dans l'héroïne
c'est votre prof de solfège de
contrepoint et d'harmonie que vous
recueillez un jour chez vous parce que
son père était mort et un jour vous le
voyez en train de se faire un fixe dans
la salle de bain et vous essayez quoi en
fait j'avais essayé un petit peu avant
je faisais un remplacement ouais je vais
avoir 16 ans quand j'ai essayé mais
c'était juste un trade héroïne nasal
quand même ça m'a rien fait
alors là évidemment quand on prend de
l'héroïne au début c'est vachement bien
on croit que tous les problèmes sont
sont réglés problème c'est après comme
on dit toujours au début on en prend
pour être bien puis après pour pas être
mal donc après on court après alors vous
essayez tout vous essayez non seulement
l'héroïne mais aussi l'héroïne mélangées
avec la cocaïne ce qu'on appelle le
Speedball le Speedball ensuite vous avez
pris du crack
[Musique]
vous ayez pas peur de vous [__] le
cerveau non non j'ai lu quelque part
qu'on utilisait on utilisait de toute
façon juste un dixième de nos neurones
dans toute une existence
et donc bon non mais j'avais pas une
approche très quantitative des choses
c'est plutôt c'est plutôt fallait tout
essayer
et puis un jour en revenant de Hollande
ou par des parties pour le ski quand le
fameux prof de solfège qui vous a initié
vous appelle il vous dit je suis mal je
suis mal viens me dépanner j'étais parti
pour décrocher en plus
donc il vous appelle je suis mal viens
viens viens viens m'aider
que je comptais pour pas être prendre
pour pas être mal le prendre le
lendemain matin et bon j'y vais passer
et puis là j'ai vu le flag on est
vraiment comme ça
vous faites ses rêves vous finissez donc
évidemment en prison alors en prison
vous dites qu'il y a pas il y a pas de
drogue évidemment il y a pas d'héroïne
mais il y a la fiole c'est quoi la fiole
mais c'est ce qu'on donne dans toute
dans toutes les prisons en France c'est
une donnes à ça pour les mecs pour parce
qu'ils sont il y a beaucoup de toxico
quand même les vols avec violence ou les
vols quels qu'ils soient enfin de la
rapine tout ça c'est vraiment
l'essentiel des gens qui ont prison
à 70% c'est lié au manque à la drogue
donc on leur donne pour les calmer pour
pas qu'ils hurle toute la nuit comme ils
sont en manque on leur donne des
tranquillisants des des opiacés des
enfin les shoot quoi
on avait prévu un jour un jour ou deux
et puis après de toute façon moi j'étais
barré quoi donc je voulais m'arrêter
donc
en fait vous lui en voulez parce que
c'est quand même trop facile d'être le
fils de Gérard Depardieu
comme ça et je serai jamais comme ça non
non j'étais condamné j'estime justement
ils en voulait faire un exemple tu crois
parce que c'était le changement de
politique tu vois c'était un peu la
droite qui venait il fallait bien
montrer que attention maintenant les
jeunes ça rigole plus et donc bah là
maintenant on continue à dérouler le
même tapis quoi donc c'est assez
intéressant de voir que ça ne sert
strictement à rien et puis on met pas
les gens qui sont malades en prison je
trouve ça ridicule vous l'avez voulu à
votre père d'avoir essayé d'intervenir
auprès de Nicolas Bazire et Balladur
vous auriez préféré finalement qui vous
laisse là pour un chien un peu qui qui
soit pas là du tout qui viennent pas en
plus me discréditer moi je veux dire je
voulais faire ma peine jusqu'au bout et
il y a pas de problème là-dessus moi je
fais ma peine c'est le même si j'estime
que j'ai rien à [__] là dedans
justement assez motivant c'est très
motivant
ce que vous vouliez vous c'était une
certaine rédemption par la punition non
pas du tout non garde d'avoir ce genre
de pensée là Julio chrétienne non merci
non non c'est plutôt
de voir de mettre les choses à plat avec
l'esprit clair et d'ouvrir dans quelle
société j'ai voulu et donc à partir de
là c'est très bien je sais que je suis
malade je sais maintenant que on prend
les malades comme ça qu'on en fait ça je
sais bref avoir les idées claires
j'étais arrêté six ans plus tard vous
êtes arrêté comment tout seul
sans rien non
sans méthadone
comme ça
dur
voilà et puis ensuite vous raconter dans
le bouquin votre amputation suite à
cette maladie nosocomiale on vous
propose soit d'avoir la jambette toute
votre vie soit de vous faire amputer ça
fait un bon petit parallèle devant les
mecs qui sont malades dans les font en
tôle et les mecs qui vont les hôpitaux
ils ont plus quoi
j'ai testé pour vous
avez préféré être amputé plutôt que
avoir la jambe droite
intenable et en faisant faire non mais
il y en a même qui m'ont dit quand même
hâte tu t'es bien démerdé t'as pas fait
comme tout le monde
il y en a qui arrivent à dire ça les
yeux dans les yeux en pensant vraiment
que c'est vrai que j'ai fait exprès
pour faire bien dans le curriculum
alors votre père vous appelle donc après
7 amputation il vous appelle à l'hôpital
il vous dit ça va comment vous dites ça
va très bien espèce de
sarcasme ça va très bien j'ai fait un
drôle de rêve papa j'étais entouré de
fille toute nue qui me sucer le moignon
oui j'ai vu tout de suite il avait des
limites au sens de l'humour
vous dites mon père je l'aime et je le
déteste pour les mêmes raisons son
impuissance non non mais c'est toujours
pareil de toute façon les gens les
aiment quand on les aime vraiment
il a pas été assez dur avec vous vous
pensez
franchement non mais c'est une manière
qui est autrement plus dure aussi de
dire à quelqu'un bah démerde toi tu vas
voir elle a dur quoi moi je trouve que
ça m'a amené vers une liberté qui est
vrai c'est vrai c'est vrai ça je dois le
concéder
je trouve que c'est intéressant de dire
à quelqu'un démerde-toi de toute façon
tu vas être bien être obligé de te
démerder donc mais c'était peut-être un
peu tôt est-ce que vous lui en voulez de
pas vous avoir donné un exemple parce
que vous dites dans le bouquin mon père
s'est fait ce que je dis ne fais pas ce
que je fais ouais vous trouvez qu'il
manque d'intégrité d'éthique
c'est-à-dire que vous pensez que
finalement quand on quand on a des trucs
soit faut le cacher vraiment quoi il
faut pas que ça se voit
en se posant en représentant aux garant
de la justice quelle qu'elle soit mais
après moi après ce que j'ai vu tu vois
c'est pas le top crédibilité quoi
oui comme tous les gens de sa génération
vous découvrez qui s'est calmé qu'il a
fait des partouts voilà comme tout
moi j'étais déjà barré depuis longtemps
quoi j'étais déjà dans ma tête c'était
j'avais 10 ans j'étais déjà dans mon
univers fallait plus m'approcher quoi
vous découvrez même qu'il a une fille
avec Karine syllabe demi-sœurs il a pas
osé vous en parler vous la prenez
parce que Karine Sila a appelé votre
père devant vous ouais pour dire que
c'était bien passé
mais vous apprenez sa vie privée par la
presse en fait ouais aujourd'hui aussi
en Irlande vous l'avez appris en disant
par exemple j'étais un peu affranchi
parce que maintenant je sais voir un peu
les rapports
je trouve ça bien moi je trouve ça bien
qu'il soit avec cette femme là
j'ai rien dit
de votre mère aussi Elisabeth Depardieu
vous dites qui sont en instance de
divorce depuis 14 ans
parce qu'il veut pas lâcher sur le plan
Antonio quoi en gros ouais mais bon
franchement c'est assez opaque hein
ma mère il veut pas divorcer parce qu'il
veut pas lâcher
d'éducation de ma mère et je trouve ça
très bien d'ailleurs c'est à dire que
moi j'avais pas plus d'argent que mon
meilleur ami et bon comme c'était une
famille nombreuse quatre enfants c'est
le milieu bon
donc moi j'ai trouvé ça très bien mais
non mais mon père il est pas du tout pas
généreux c'est pas vrai faut pas faut
pas qu'on croise ça non plus c'est
quelqu'un qui a du mal à filer une pièce
par contre il peut te filer une brique
bon moi j'ai pas j'ai pas tendance à
demander facilement une brique
vous avez divorcé ça a été réglé avec
Elise j'ai pas attendu 14 ans quoi ouais
on est oui on est en train de faire
heureusement que j'ai Louise quand même
non
quand votre père a lu le bouquin il nous
a dit que certains passages étaient pas
bien qu'ils étaient introuvés
intéressant il le prend
s'il voit un truc et après il le lit
mais bon là il avait juste parcouru
trois feuillets il a dit oui Francis
pour me dire qu'il trouvait ça un
pudique
vous le trouviez
il l'a lu maintenant je pense vous avez
pas une nouvelle non il vous répond en
en gala vous l'avez lu ah ben oui j'ai
eu des nouvelles par exemple c'est
terrible ce qu'il dit parce que en fait
il dit bah si ça l'aide d'écrire ce
bouquin tant mieux pour lui si elle vous
attendez comme attitude vous avez
attendu quelque chose de plus violent
franchement je m'en fous
ça me m’empêche pas de dormir et c'est
pas ça qui me fait lever le matin
maintenant vous avez Facebook vous
sentez libéré de quelque chose
ouais je sens en tout cas on me posera
plus les mêmes questions à chaque fois
que je viendrai faire la promo pour un
truc que j'ai fait que j'estime qui est
bien et qui mérite plus largement de
l'attention plutôt que sur ma famille ou
quoi que ce soit comme ça là je l'ai
fait aussi pour ça quoi j'ai trouvé bien
mon intérêt là-dedans
qu'on fasse plus chier avec ma famille
mais alors
je trouve ça infernal c'est terrible ça
les gens vont se lasser attention Gérard
c'est la dernière fois que vous en
parler là alors
[Rires]
[Musique]
d'Alain Delon non
non ça va comme ça ça va comme ça ça
vous suffit c'est pas mal
[Musique]
alors Guillaume vous avez eu des hauts
vous avez eu des barbes vous faire une
interview up and down
[Musique]
ce que vous préférez chez vous
la qualité de mes silences
c'est que vous voyez c'est chez vous la
qualité de mes silence
au cinéma ce que vous préférez
au cinéma
les gens les rencontres parce que cinéma
la naissance de ma fille le pire
le pire la naissance de ton père
[Rires]
[Musique]
je sais pas encore non ce qui vous plaît
le plus dans la vie
après l'amour
ce qui vous plaît le MOINS
attendre avant
votre plus gros coup de fric
c'est un truc que j'ai pas fait
justement c'est pour faire monter les
enchères pour voir jusqu'où il pouvait
aller
le plus grosses perte
c'est ça s'il l'a pas fait
[Rires]
Laurent Baffie
et la plus minable la plus minable le
jour où j'ai failli tomber amoureux de
moi
quel soleil de plus sexy en vous je sais
pas et de moi c'est que
quand je suis bourré
est-ce que vous préférez dans le sexe
moi j'aime tout
ce que vous détestez dans le sexe
les interdits et pour être sûr de ne
rien rater de Inna Lady tube
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu